this is a foxes alert tonight multiple
people are dead including an officer
after a shooting at a supermarket
in boulder colorado here with the very
latest from the scene is around alicia
acuna is with us alicia
terrible what we're hearing you just had
a press conference as well
you were attending
yes and good evening sean the boulder
police
commander here telling us that yes in
fact they did lose one of their own
tonight
one of their officers killed in the line
of duty while responding to the shooting
at the king supers here in boulder
additionally he said that they have
multiple fatalities however
he said right now they are having
conversations with the family members of
those killed
inside of this grocery store this
afternoon and so therefore they will not
be releasing any more information
including how many people they believe
died inside that store because right now
they are also
processing the crime scene and as the
commander here put it they are still
making
new discoveries what we also don't know
is what the motive is here we do
know that there is one suspect who is
being treated
at a hospital right now he is also in
custody
however his identity any details about
him
not being released at this point so we
will continue to follow this as the
evening goes on boulder police will be
giving more updates
as the evening continues sean all right
alicia
thank you now as we mentioned